if you're trying to balance your
personal and your business life the most
important thing you can do is set
boundaries
set boundaries for what is your business
time what are you working on and don't
allow for interruptions
and same thing on the personal side
set boundaries don't let people don't
let your business trounce into it if
you've dedicated that time for your
personal life
got a question from a reader great
question rajiv who wrote in to say i'd
like to discipline my business life at
the same time balance my personal
private life can you help me so rajiv
here are some of the things i do and
hopefully can help
i'm not in the office that much
i'm in the office on monday to thursday
and
i usually
get in now i get in
around 10 15
and i'll work for an hour and a half
then take a break and then i'll come
back work for another hour half in the
afternoon and at 3 15 i'm done
3 15 i go and i go pick up my son and
then it's personal time
and i try not to let things bleed
one into the other it definitely helps
having a different space to go to so i
have an office that i come to on my
monday to thursday
if you're working from home have a
dedicated space that when you're there
people know you're working you're not
getting distracted you're not doing
other stuff
and when you leave then you're focused
on on the rest of your life
i treat my personal time as an important
meeting
just as important as anything else in my
business
so you're scheduling out
what helped me at the beginning was
i mapped out
where do i need to spend my time like
how much time do i want to send with my
family how much time do i spend on my
business what are the things i need to
work on
and then plot it out on my calendar
and left time and in my business there
are projects that i have to work on that
are
projects that you know i wasn't able to
give off anybody yet or things i'm
testing
and i always make sure i have room for
ceo time and that's time to focus on
growing the business not just being in
the business running the business but
big picture growing the business ideas
i like to chunk it in an hour and a half
because i find that those chunks are
it's ideal
for
for workflow i find that if you're
working for more than an hour and a half
your brain starts to shut off
so
i try to focus my efforts on an hour and
a half and i don't allow distractions
nobody has my phone number my phone is
in the closet in in my office i don't
know the phone number from my cell phone
people don't call me i don't get
distracted by email and that gives me
focused chunks so when i'm sitting down
i'm working for an hour and a half i am
working for an hour and a half and
nobody's distracting me from doing what
i have to do and when i'm playing with
my son i'm playing with my son
and nobody's distracting me from
something else i don't take
emails from my office when i'm playing
with my son
how much time you spend working how much
time you spend with your family we all
have to make our own personal decisions
on what to do there
and that's fine
figure it out
drop your calendar
see how much time you want to work on
your business
okay if you're working nine to five if
that's your calendar or you're working
you know ten to eight or whatever it is
plot that out make sure that those times
spent are focused not getting distracted
you're setting boundaries so people can
interrupt you on important things you
have to do and that includes your family
and includes your your staff and your
suppliers
my family all knows that when i'm
working i'm working and not to interrupt
me unless it's an emergency right this
is an emergency if somebody calls me my
family has my cell phone number i'm
picking it up because i know it's an
emergency
but it almost never happens when do we
really get emergencies you know maybe a
couple times a year
so i don't really factor it in
but of course if something comes up i
drop everything else
and you also factor in your family time
or other hobbies that you have i spend
20 25 hours a week doing salsa salsa
dancing djing preparing my list
it's crazy i gotta factor that in i
schedule that
and i don't let things get in the way
with my salsa when i'm out dancing or
djing i'm not answering my emails or
doing other business
so focus set boundaries don't let things
interrupt you most of your time is
wasted from hopping between
different things in a day
you're working on something you're doing
really well at it and then an email
comes in you get distracted you go look
at it or a phone call comes in you get
distracted then you come back to your
email you come back to your project and
what was i working on i don't remember
what i was doing
don't let that happen focus
you have to tell people how you want to
be treated
if you want to book a call with me or
book a meeting with me i send you a link
to my calendar
and you book it in there's no back and
forth on email does this day work does
this day work this time doesn't work for
me
you adapt to my calendar
if you respect your time
other people will respect your time
if you don't then people will walk all
over you so you have to respect your
time you have to set boundaries and you
have to treat your personal life just as
important as your business
believe
for those of you watching you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
make sure to do more for you and hey i'd
love to hear what you have to think
about this video please leave a comment
below they make my day even if you're
just saying great video evan i love
seeing us come in and if you have a
comment or question for your own company
let me know and i'll create a video
reply for you thank you guys see you
soon